director Park how did you make it
comfortable for the actors on set
knowing that this is a very integral
part of the movie very beautifully done
but also could be very uncomfortable at
parts for them how did you make it so
that the set was more comfortable either
a clothes that keep it light make jokes
how did you do it was no jokes that he
would make two try and hate that it's
been like if you have the time to making
jokes use that time to proceed quickly
that's the better way to do it what's
most important is not what happens on
the set but during what happens during
the pre-production what you do during
that stage is the most important thing
and and when I approached these these
kinds of scenes it's not just about not
just in the writing of the script but I
do I tend to do a thorough storyboard
and through the through the
storyboarding the stage I plan things as
specific and detailed as possible
through doing things that way the actors
are able to see exactly what to expect
for those scenes because they see it on
the page and they are able to be
prepared mentally going into those
things and when the time comes when you
get to it on set the most important
thing is to do it quickly and get it
over that with Georgia park I believe
you said previously that you're not the
kind of film maker that aims to send a
message although you're not opposed to
it so then what makes you decide to take
on a certain project well it's old it
all depends on how much the story pulls
me into it how much I Mesmer mesmerized
by the story what I feel about any given
story in terms of how I respond to it
instinctively is the most important
thing for me for this project however
it's a slightly different from that from
that case
this is a film with certainly a message
something to say because this film had
the message destroying her the message
where the woman who had been oppressed
by the part of violent male gaze through
solidarity forming solidarity between
the two they're able to escape from it
was the crux of the story beautiful film
including